i was doing some research the other day
when i came across this image of a
battleship just exploding it's a pretty
gnarly photo i mean you can clearly see
the blast wave hitting the water after
staring at it a moment i realized i
wasn't looking at an explosion hitting
the ship i was looking at the most
absurdly oversized muzzle flash i'd ever
seen the ship was actually firing
several massive guns all at the same
time and that's when i realized that i
know almost nothing about battleships or
naval warfare for that matter all of
these questions come to mind like how
big are the ships how powerful are they
what kind of guns do they have how do
they float and the more i researched the
more i discovered just how impressive
these vessels really are and the feat of
engineering it takes to create them so
when world of warships reached out to me
asking if i would like to make a video i
was like yes please let me do it because
i wanted to share some of the crazier
things i've learned so sit back relax
and come on this journey with me while
we discover some cool fun facts about
warships we're going places that we
can't normally go
[Music]
first things first why don't battleships
just sink they're these huge
amalgamations of metal and concrete that
somehow float how is this even possible
well something you might not realize
that is actually really interesting
about water is that it is heavy
like really heavy a 1 meter cube of it
weighs a metric ton or 2 200 pounds this
box of water weighs more than 16 people
and that's just because water is super
dense it weighs a lot the whole idea of
floating is based on the fact that if
something is lighter than water it stays
on top of that water but boats and ships
are heavier than water as evidenced by
all the ships at the bottom of the ocean
and yet they're somehow normally
floating on top the thing is though is
that they are shaped in a way to
displace water pushing it aside
replacing it with just empty air and
even though boats are heavy the water
they push aside is heavier and that's
the entire idea they're pushing aside
water that weighs more than them that
displaced water exerts an upward force
on the boats keeping them afloat and
that is called buoyancy and that's what
keeps pretty much all boats afloat the
crazy thing is that there's not really
an upper limit to this concept you can
have a boat the size of a city as long
as it weighs less than the water it
pushes aside our limits there are mostly
with material science and engineering
but it's certainly not for lack of
trying we've tried to make some very big
boats aircraft carriers are some of the
largest floating things in existence
take the uss enterprise for example it
was commissioned in the mid 23rd century
by the federation starfleet to help
explo oh wait that's no that's not right
wrong enterprise hold up backup the uss
enterprise aircraft carrier which is
actually the eighth ship to carry that
enterprise name was the first
nuclear-powered aircraft carrier and
surf for over 50 years aircraft carriers
are massive because they're not only
actual runways for airplanes but they're
also home to thousands of sailors and
dozens of aircrafts freaking floating
aircraft hangar the uss enterprise in
particular is the longest warship to
have ever been created with a length of
1123 feet if stood vertically it would
stand about a hundred feet taller than
the us bank building in downtown los
angeles that would make it taller than
every single building in the entire
state of california even in new york
city it'd become the seventh largest
building and actually maybe blend in you
wouldn't be able to tell it's there okay
yeah warships are big but let's bring it
back to battleships for a moment
remember that photo from the beginning
of the video well it turns out that that
ship is the decommissioned uss iowa
which is now a museum here in long beach
that's actually really close to us so
obviously we had to go check it out look
at these guns oh my god the most
interesting thing about this ship in my
opinion is the fact that it has three
turrets each with three guns and each of
those guns have bullets that are 16
inches in diameter this was also
outfitted at one point to take on
nuclear shells so imagine like a bullet
that's also a nuclear bomb
this is the biggest bullet barrel i've
ever seen bullet barrel
bullet bill i mean obviously it's not
the paris gun shooting from other
countries but you know fun fact this
ship is about four feet longer than the
titanic this entire thing is the turret
and this isn't even actually attached to
the ship it's just sitting here it's
just like dropped in if this was to
capsize it would fall out and sink these
guns are so powerful that they've
created this misconception that if you
were to fire all nine of them sideways
at the exact same time that the ship
wouldn't be able to handle it and it
would just rock over upside down but
that doesn't happen because water is
super heavy don't forget and it acts as
a buffer so yeah the ship might move
like maybe three to six feet sideways
but it's not going to capsize not even
close
and these are 50 caliber guns meaning
that the barrel length is 50 times
longer than the diameter of the bullet
that it fires and the bullets oh my god
the bullets are massive they're 16
inches in diameter 6 feet tall and weigh
2 700 pounds they weigh as much as
nick's car so every time this ship fires
one of those bullets it's as if it's
firing a kia soul that's a lot of
hamsters so as you can see we have six
of these 110 pound explosive bags and
they're filled with just like this
explosive propellant that all explodes
at the same time firing this bullet
super far but here's where my mind was
truly blown away regarding these guns
not only are the bullets themselves like
stupid heavy but they can be fired
really far the mark viii gun turrets of
this ship can actually fire projectiles
24 miles away now 24 miles might not
seem like all that far it's less
distance than a marathon but that's
still so far away the ship can't even
see the target it's shooting at let me
show you what i mean so if you were to
actually look out at the horizon while
standing on the coast of the ocean you'd
only be seeing about three miles before
the curvature of the earth starts hiding
everything behind it because you know
the earth is round and we're actually
standing about 100 feet up on the water
right now so we can even see further but
even the rangefinder of the uss can only
see about 16 miles so anything beyond
that is just hidden by the horizon
imagine this you know jpl the jet
propulsion lab in pasadena they're the
ones responsible for putting you know
robotic rovers on mars well let's say
that the martians aren't too happy about
us driving around on their turf and they
decide to invade the jpl facility in
order to stop us theoretically to defend
ourselves we could just dock the ship in
santa monica and be within firing range
of the mothership talk about defending
earth with 1940s technology and fire
now even though this round is flying at
a crazy fast velocity at maximum range
it still takes about a minute and a half
to reach the target it has a time of
flight of about 86 seconds and since i
wanted to play this entire shot out in
real time that actually gives me a
moment to talk to you about world of
warships legends it is the latest
version of the warships franchise built
from the ground up with console gaming
in mind i've personally been playing on
the playstation 4 but you can play on
xbox or pc as well legends puts the
power of history's greatest warships
into your hands allowing you to recruit
legendary commanders and fight for naval
supremacy with other players around the
world the game has officially launched
with more content achievements and ships
than ever before including the infamous
german battleship terpits which is now
the most powerful ship in the game and
only available for the next few weeks
world of warships legends is available
to play right now for free and if you
want to experience what it's like to
fire all nine of these guns at the same
time click the link in the description
so you can start playing it today and
boom the martians have now been taken
out and earth has been saved again but
you know what could have also taken out
the martian ships
freaking guided cruise missiles dude and
that's actually why we don't see
battleships anymore in any navy they've
become obsolete in today's modern world
it's all about air superiority and less
about direct naval engagements
battleships like the uss iowa were all
about having thick armor and big guns
but were ultimately too costly to
operate compared to smaller and faster
cruisers that could launch missiles from
a much longer range in spite of that
however battleships are still incredibly
impressive feats of engineering
especially considering that this ship
was built almost 80 years ago it stands
as a testament to human ingenuity and
gumption in a time where problems
couldn't be solved by just simply
googling the answer